are you guys doing today good how are
you
nice to see you guys congrats on your
first uh studio movie if you will thank
you so much thank you
i am curious what do you um this is your
first time working with this cat like
what cast like like this if you will
what do you think is there anything that
you wish you knew on day one that you
now know after making a movie like this
well that's a great question we haven't
been asked that before i think
one thing that we
have always
honestly there's nothing that i think i
would change but i i think we knew paul
walter hauser was a secret weapon maybe
not as much of a secret weapon now
we're like oh we can't wait for everyone
to see uh his character and see uh that
he really uh he just makes every movie
better that's a good answer it's very
true by the way i i completely agree 100
he's a secret weapon no doubt yeah
maybe you won't be a secret after queen
pimps
oh that might be true i uh i think one
of the things about this movie is that
everybody has used a coupon or if you
haven't used a coupon you're an anomaly
and you know i i guess can you sort of
talk about what is it about um
the coupon culture that is maybe right
for telling a story like this yeah well
we took a deep dive in the world of
coupons and there's so much of a
psychological effect of using coupons
the coupon high but also the foundation
of our economy runs off of coupons and
what we realized is that someone a
company like jcpenney when they decided
to get rid of coupons all across the
board they lost four billion dollars and
almost went bankrupt and almost went
bankrupt and so what we discovered
through our research is that when people
ask the question is it a need or is it a
want you know they will then decide if
they're going to purchase something but
if you have a coupon and you decide to
use it as a ticking clock on it all of a
sudden if it's a need or a wand it's no
longer a wand it always becomes a need
because now you feel the pressure to buy
so coupons essentially are the ticket to
continuing buying in our economy and i
think we did see a statistic where 96 of
americans have used a coupon before so
it is an anomaly if you're if you
haven't
um one of the things that i appreciate
about this movie is that your the best
friends do not have the typical falling
out in the second act like they're legit
best friends and they're trying to work
together for each other you sort of talk
about that aspect of the script well
thank you for recognizing thank you
because that was something that we
talked about we said let's avoid
that sort of cliche or trope and we
worked really hard to
make sure that it was this friendship
that was strong throughout and they were
dealing with all of these external
forces that they had to you know
overcome obstacles but it wasn't about
them having some sort of fight you know
two-thirds of the way through and
moping around for 10 minutes and then
coming back together stronger but that
was something that we really discussed
in writing it and wanted to avoid that
and it was so important to us because
aaron and i would say you know like we
have friends we've been friends with for
25 years and we've never going through
difficult times ever turned on each
other
but let's make this really a story about
what happens in real life which is
there's a huge obstacle yeah you support
your friends there's a huge obstacle in
the way let's figure out how to tackle
the obstacle in your way and get over it
together and get over it together and
that's erin and i are best friends even
though we're also married
and we also talk about all the obstacles
in our way and we don't turn on each
other we really just want to support
each other and get through it
uh on that note i gotta stop i'm just
gonna say congrats on your movie i had a
great time watching it i hope you guys
are making another studio film again
very soon oh
thank you so much have a great day thank
you